hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy which you probably know
is a not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and not-for-profit
means no one owns khan academy we are a
public charity you own as much of khan
academy as i do
it's there for the public good and the
way that we're able to provide
this service the videos the software the
exercises for
free to tens of millions of learners
around the world
is because of philanthropic donations
from generous folks like yourself
so if you're in a position to do so
please think about making a donation to
khan academy
as you probably know in 2020 the world
leaned more heavily on khan academy than
ever before to keep the learning going
during the pandemic we had 12 billion
learning minutes on the platform last
year 6 billion
students coming on their own 6 billion
is hundreds of thousands of teachers
getting their students to do it as part
of the
distance learning classroom experience
during the pandemic
and as now we get hopefully to the light
at the end of the tunnel
on the pandemic and hopefully over the
next couple of months
things are able to normalize it's even
more important that we don't let
up because when all of the stuff has
been thrown up into the air we one need
to make sure that as it falls things
don't break
students have accrued gaps in their
learning
teachers need more support families need
more support
and also there's a unique window of time
right now
over the next six to 12 months where as
things come back to earth not only
should they not break
but there's an opportunity to make sure
that the post-pandemic world could even
be better than the pre-pandemic world
a world where every student is able to
fill in their gaps
learn at their own time or space and
really reach whatever that potential is
that every teacher has the tools to
personalize for their students
and feels optimally informed and
optimally empowered and every parent
feels like there are resources
regardless of your zip code regardless
of your income
where your children can reach their
potential
so i hope you can consider making a
donation in particular we're hoping to
get at least
12 000 new donors of any level any
donation makes a huge difference
to become part of this mission to
provide a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere